send in the troops Democrats are
beginning to sound like Republicans as
crime continues to explode in their
cities take D.C which is on Pace to have
the deadliest year in two decades
shocking security footage just released
shows the moment when one of Senator
Rand Paul staffers was randomly stabbed
while walking around in our nation's
capital back in March police say the
suspect had been released from prison
just a day earlier
and it was a blood-soaked start to this
month The Surge of shootings in D.C left
13 people dead in the first five days
Democratic D.C council member thinks
it's time the National Guards step in to
restore order
I have spoken with the DC National Guard
and while I have to have more
conversations with the chief police
which I have today and the mayor and my
colleagues
we have a long way to get there
we just know that police alone is not
getting it done and we are clearly
our government has to step up our Police
Department had to step up and our
residents have to step up we're tired of
this
and enough is enough excuse my language
but I want to be quite frankly wow but
that's what happens when it's all crime
and no punishment D.C didn't prosecute
67 percent of those arrested last year
thanks to the fund the police
I I mean Greg I think we're now reaching
a point where people in these cities
Democrats are begging for someone to do
something forgive me if I sound a bit
racist but these stories seem to all
look alike yes meaning in each case
Trump offered a solution for it years
ago and was condemned in every case in
every case he said something like you
need more police you need the National
Guard and because I call it what do I
call it the Trump containment disorder
contamination disorder you can't be seen
agreeing with anything that Trump
believes in right because you can't beat
a cocktail party and say I agree with
Donald Trump it's how Petty the media is
they'd rather argue against a good point
than defend and actually defend the
criminal than be seen somehow on the
same side As Trump the problem with
these cities is a lot of the good people
are going to leave and they are and then
all you're going to have is bad people
there which are the criminals you can't
if if you enforce Law and Order on just
the law abiding that doesn't make any
sense right it's you create a murder
capital and you're a coward it's
interesting that you have white liberals
pretty well off saying you know no bail
defund the police let's not even talk
about the crime and then you have black
politicians in the streets in these
urban areas saying please help us so
several years ago during the George
Floyd riots Senator Tom Cotton placed an
op-ed in the New York Times in which he
said we need the National Guard and it
was so outrageous to the left that two
of the editors at the New York Times got
fired right for allowing someone to
express their opinion in the in the New
York Times after it had gone through an
exhausting and excruciating fact check
process so and I'm not exactly sure but
I think the same city councilman had a
different point of view three years ago
what's changed the situation is so dire
the number of homicides is up an
incredible amount and he was responding
reacting to a mass shooting that
happened on Saturday night and we had
one of the mothers of the young men that
was killed he was 35 years old his name
was Bernard B.J Hodges and he worked
three jobs he took care of three kids he
took care of took care of his wife he
went to school to become an HVAC
engineer to make sure that he actually
had real good solid work he'd get up in
the morning he'd go work for the water
treatment system in Washington D.C and
she said there's just no there's no one
that is putting up structures like she
said like a Rec Center there's some
place where they could hang out because
what's happening is they're hanging out
in the corner and then the whole idea of
snitching has become something that is
so bad that nobody wants to talk to
anybody else about what's hap what's
really happening so then the police
they're outmanned they don't have any
intel so they can't really do anything
about it and then if they do something
about it the people aren't prosecuted so
I I understand the need for the National
Guard I don't know if that will actually
happen but I think that as James Freeman
of the Wall Street Journal said today
like instead of defund the police like
the chant could be help the police and
maybe then the prosecutors would take an
interest
since black lives matter we all agree
Joe Biden said it himself do you think
since black lives matter Joe Biden would
send in the National Guard to D.C to
save black lives
I think that Joe Biden would be open to
any conversation that meant that more
people
would have a better quality of life and
not be victims of violent crimes
I don't know I didn't I didn't call him
about it but I think that he would be
open to any of these conversations he's
shown himself to be that way and also
he's been more conservative on crime and
policing than majority of the Democrats
who were running for office certainly in
the Democratic Primary in 2020 I think
it's absolutely heartbreaking it was a
wonderful interview this morning
um with B.J Hodges mother and I hate to
see this I do also hate when the
conversation is just isolated around
liberal CD liberal cities when there are
crime waves going on all over the
country in cities like Omaha and
Nebraska which has a Republican mayor
for all of you keyboard Warriors at home
are about to tweet at me that that's not
the case Jesse Waters is number one or
like in Tulsa Oklahoma why does
Jacksonville now have a Democratic mayor
because the Republican mayor failed to
keep crime under control and so he was
replaced same in Colorado Springs where
now there's an independent marriage in
an instance though it always goes back
to Liberal policies unfortunately
you can cherry pick again it's always
little
I'm not just cherry picking it I'm
trying to be accurate about what's going
on across the country like New York City
is doing a lot better than it was the
murder rate is down the violent crime
rate is down we should start
at the low that's like bragging the gas
prices just to what no we're just trying
to be accurate here's a try harder
here's a problem with all of this that
that the innocent people have to stand
by and suffer as the left keeps making
the same hair brain mistakes because
they're too slow on the uptake okay we
had a problem with crime in the 90s we
resolved it and we were in great shape
why because we increased police on the
street we made sure that people were
prosecuted and then the citizen was safe
now the left hasn't learned from that so
they have to pull us back so we have to
learn the same thing all over again by
saying no get rid of the police and
it'll be it will solve the criminal
problem get rid of the police because
you know there's serial races murderers
okay and then now they're saying well
maybe you should bring in the National
Guard this from the same group for years
hates the National Guard they hate the
military they hate the flag they hate
anything that has to do with Law and
Order in the military and it takes him
this long to come around and say gee
maybe that might make sense and the idea
of 67 percent of the arrest not being
prosecuted you know whose fault that is
Merrick Garland it goes right to his
door because it is the United States
Attorney who was in charge of the
prosecution of crime in the District of
Columbia which is not a state and if you
were refusing 67 percent of the arrest
everybody knows that 67 percent of the
arrest probably represents one quarter
of the crime that's committed and that's
because Garland and Biden don't
prioritize crime and in the in the end
the the idea of Martial law that when
someone even mentioned it during the
Trump Administration the left went crazy
and now the left is bringing up martial
law but how many people had to die in
the years since then how many people had
to suffer how many people had to had to
suffer a a loss of someone that they
loved terrible that's because the left
policies they go through the mistakes
over and over again when we had them all
figured out but Trump brought up martial
law when there were peaceful protests
going on yeah
the protests in 2020 were some of the
worst in the country they were tearing
down buildings police precincts and
neighborhoods and businesses so I
wouldn't compare like a one-on-one
although I spent my life doing that to
what was going on in 2020. we have to
leave it there that's a shame I know
Brian Kilmeade I want you to do me a
favor I want you to click to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page this is
this is the way that I
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on Fox
you can get it all here on YouTube so
subscribe right now